The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare@OCW.MIT.edu
OLIVIER DE WECK: Seven
miscellaneous topics, and you
may be wondering,
well, what are those?
So I'd like to start with
a general status update,
and then we'll go
over the master
solution for the online quiz
that you took this week.
And then, I think,
in about 10 minutes,
we're going to have an
interactive discussion
with the INCOSE
board of directors.
And so, we'll probably not get
through all the master solution
discussion by the time they
dial in, and that's OK.
You know, we'll just have a
15, 20 minute chat with them.
The reason we're doing
this is because they're
at MIT right now for
a three day meeting,
so INCOSE's the
International National
Council of System Engineering.
And so we thought it would be
a nice thing since, you know,
this is a systems engineering
class, to tie in with them
and hear a little bit
of their perspective
on what's happening in
industry and in, sort of,
the bigger picture.
And hopefully, some
of you have got
a couple of questions
prepared, so we can have
sort of a dialogue with them.
That's the general idea.
And then we have a
presentation prepared.
The Octanis I project will be
presented from EPFL, to us,
and I think you'll
find it very exciting.
And so, as we listen
to that presentation,
put on your system
engineering thinking hat,
and then hopefully we'll have
time for discussion as well.
Let me just remind
you briefly where we
stand in terms of the class--
in the V-Model, in particular.
We made great progress,
and we've essentially
covered the whole
left side, the bottom.
And what we'll do
starting next week,
is really climb up
on the right side.
So next week's topic
is System Integration
and Interface Management.
Then we'll cover Verification
Validation, Commissioning
and Operations.
And then our final
official lecture
is Lifecycle Management.
We do have a 12th lecture on
Prototyping and Manufacturing.
That window is
optional because this
is after the official
end of classes at MIT.
So you're not expected
to participate,
but you're invited to.
So basically, the focus
in the next month or so
is covering the right side of V.
So let me start talking
about the midterm exam.
And we'll sort of go
question by question,
and please stop me if you have
any comments or questions.
Let's make this interactive.
So question one, if a complex
electromechanical system has
1,850 individual part numbers--
this is at the lowest level--
how many levels do you expect
the drawing tree to have?
Everybody provided the
same answer, four, right?
This is basically a
straight application
of the magic number seven rule.
And in practice, not
everybody will go exactly
for four levels, but
that's the basic idea.
If you decompose the system with
this human cognitive bandwidth
in mind, for a system of
that level of complexity,
you should expect, roughly,
a four layer decomposition.
So I'm very pleased that
everybody got this answer.
But with the caveat
that there may
be deviations from
this rule, and you
can go for a flatter
tree with fewer levels.
But you have to be aware
of the implications
that that may have.
OK, so that's great.
The next question was--
OK, so you're attending
a cocktail party--
and cocktail parties, I don't
think that's-- that maybe
that's very 20th century.
I don't think we have cocktail
parties anymore, so maybe more
like a Google Hangout or
the 21st century equivalent.
But the basic idea
here is, how would you
explain what system
engineering is
to somebody who is not
a technical person, not
an engineer?
And I think most of you--
I looked through all the
answers, and most of you
basically provided a definition
of system engineering
that we would use in
this class, right.
So it was like, OK, well, not
quite what I was looking for
but not incorrect.
So I pulled out two
examples that I kind of
liked because they brought in
analogies from other fields
as to what system
engineering is.
So the first one here is, OK,
so system engineering represents
a method but also a mindset
that enables the design and so
forth of successful systems,
but systems engineering
is like cooking
a delicious cake.
OK, so it's like cooking
a delicious recipe.
You've got your ingredients
which is your part
numbers, or your parts, right?
You have a process
that you're following.
And at the end of it you
should have something special,
something delicious,
something wholesome,
something that is greater
than the sum of the parts.
I don't know if any of you
watch the Food Channel?
Anybody watching the
Food Network here?
Yeah?
OK.
We actually like to watch it.
It's kind of fun.
And what's fun is when you give
the same ingredients to, like,
half a dozen different people--
and same ingredients,
same amount of time,
and the result that comes out
of it is vastly different.
Now, why is that?
Of course, you can say
skills and so forth,
but it is fundamentally,
because those ingredients--
that details matter.
The way in which the
ingredients get combined.
And you know, did you
use the right heat?
Did you did you take
it off the heat?
30 seconds too soon or too
late, those little details
make a huge difference
to the final product, OK.
And that's what I think what's
cool about the Food Network
and cooking in general.
Cuisine, it's an art.
It's not just follow the recipe.
And so, I think that's
a great analogy.
I like that.
And then the other one is--
so you're talking
to Cher, the singer,
and explain to her that system
engineering is like a concert.
So in a concert you have
all your specialists, right?
You have your choir maybe.
You have your strings section.
You have your trumpets.
And I think it's
kind of similar.
You could have great
individual musicians,
but if the conductor is not
bringing everybody into harmony
then you get a cacophony.
It's not a great result.
So a great orchestra
is not just a bunch of
great individual musicians,
but it's the idea that
you're orchestrating--
there's something
special that emerges
if you synchronize everybody in
a way-- and you motivate them,
and you synchronize them,
and something really special
happens.
I think that's another
great sort of example
of what we mean by
system engineering
in the technical world.
This idea of a conductor
bringing everybody in harmony,
and the end result is
something really special.
That's a little bit what I was
looking for in this answer,
and I like both
of these examples.
The third question
was about the V-Model.
And I think, based on what I
looked through the answers,
I think most people
really understood that.
And just to summarize, again,
in a very, very simple way what
the V-Model is all
about-- so here's
the V. If you wanted
to really simplify it,
we start at the upper
left with a vision.
You know, what is it that
we're trying to accomplish?
And that's where you
need to understand,
who's the stakeholder,
who are the customers,
the thing that you're about
to create doesn't exist yet.
In some projects you actually
start with an initial system,
and you need to improve it.
So you're starting with
generation N of a product,
and the goal is to create
generation N plus 1, which is
better in several dimensions.
So that's possible,
but let's just
say we have a clean
sheet situation.
And you have a vision
that you're developing.
And then you [INAUDIBLE]
TINA: Hi, Ollie, is that you?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Aha, OK.
TINA: All right, you are
now connected on speaker
with the INCOSE
Board of Directors.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Fantastic, can you hear me?
GUEST SPEAKER: No.
TINA: Yes, we can.
GUEST SPEAKER: Loud and clear.
OLIVIER DE WECK: All
right, this is great.
So I was just going over the
midterm exam that we just had,
and so I will stop doing that
because we're very glad that we
can spend time with you.
So let's make this
bigger on our end.
And do you have a camera
on your end, Tina?
DAVID: Let's say no because
of the demographics here,
so we'll have to
go on voice, Ollie.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK,
Tina, can we see you?
Can we see one of you at least?
[INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE] can stand
there at look presidential.
GUEST SPEAKER:
We're working on it.
TINA: How about I figure it
out while you give the intro?
DAVID: There you go.
Thank you, Tina.
GUEST SPEAKER: Multi-task.
OLIVIER DE WECK: It
would be helpful to see
at least who is speaking.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
DAVID: I know, we've
got a problem here.
TINA: All right, you
stand over there.
I'll point this to you.
DAVID: Well, shall we go ahead
and kick off here, Ollie?
I know your time is valuable.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
Ryan can we make
the INCOSE Board
of Directors the
main screen here?
Just give me one
second on our end.
GUEST SPEAKER: Ollie,
can I suggest we just
press ahead despite the desire
to see David's shiny face?
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
All right, so David, it's
great to talk to you.
So let me just give you a
little bit of background here.
We have about 20
students here at MIT.
Currently, we're
taking the Fundamentals
of Systems Engineering class.
We're roughly midterm, a
little bit past the midterm.
And then we have about 20
students, maybe 15 students,
and staff at EPFL
in Switzerland,
and we're teaching this class
in the form of the SPOC, Small
Private Online Course.
And so, welcome to MIT, to
the INCOSE Board of Directors.
I know you've already had
very productive times.
And we're really excited to
hear from you as to not just
what is INCOSE, but
where do you see
Systems Engineering as a field
of study and practice stand.
You know, what are the
exciting things happening?
What are the challenges?
And whatever you would
choose to share with us.
So, David.
DAVID: Very good.
Thanks, Ollie.
And thank you for making
the time available.
It is always great to talk
with the next generation.
I'll give you just a
few comments up front
and then really open it up.
For those who aren't
familiar with INCOSE,
it's the International Council
on Systems Engineering.
It's about 25 years old, about
10,000 members worldwide.
And the value of
INCOSE, fundamentally,
is to serve as a connector
across the systems community,
across organizational
boundaries,
across geographic boundaries,
so that we can connect
the practice in the US to
Europe to Asia and beyond--
they are applied differently--
and across domain boundaries,
from military and aerospace,
where we have our foundation,
to automotive to medical devices
and beyond.
If you look at it as
systems engineers,
that's perhaps the most exciting
thing of what's going on.
If you look at how complexity
continues to emerge and grow,
the problems that we are
being asked to tackle,
the technologies
at our disposal,
the opportunities for
wonderful outcomes,
the dangers and risks of
unintended consequences--
the challenges that
the world faces are,
absolutely, System's challenges.
And they are far beyond
the traditional aerospace
and defense domain.
They are everywhere.
I was with GM earlier this week,
looking at automated driving
and auto assist.
I was with medical devices
in iRobot yesterday.
And wherever you look,
whatever domain you work in,
we see complexity, we
see systems challenges,
and we see tremendous
opportunities for us,
as professionals,
but more than that,
for systems professionals to
have a profound positive impact
on the world.
So it's going to be a
very challenging journey.
We are still working to
solidify our foundation
to advance our theories,
to advance our practice.
But it is a very fruitful
time, I think, as well.
So those were the comments
that I will offer at the start,
and then open it up to the
class to ask the questions
of this board of directors.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK,
David, that was great.
And so, who wants to be first?
Don't be shy-- either
here at MIT or at EPFL.
Sam, go for it.
SAM: I was wondering when
you're creating, I guess,
INCOSE standards for systems
engineering processes,
what considerations do you
take into account in order
to make them applicable for
such a wide range of disciplines
or domains?
DAVID: Introduce yourself
for whoever speaks.
PAUL: this is Paul
Schreinmarkers.
I'm the technical director.
Thank you for asking.
Well, actually, INCOSE is
not a standard setting body,
but we are supporting a lot
of standards like ISO 15288.
And what we at
least try to achieve
is that the standards are being
applied in multiple domains
as much as possible.
Does that answer your question?
SAM: Yeah, thanks.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
OK, and just so you
know we do have
15288 as one of the--
in the class here, we covered,
sort of, three standards.
One is the System Engineering
Handbook, the [? NASA, ?]
of course, the INCOSE
Handbook, and then 15288.
So I think the students
should be familiar
with [? 15288, ?]
so that was good.
OK, can we have a
question from EPFL?
Are you still with us, guys?
- Hello, do you hear me?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yes, good.
- OK, yes.
[INAUDIBLE] just have a question
about the complexity of systems
with new systems being more
and more complex over time,
would system engineers,
or engineering itself,
have to reinvent
itself in the future?
And what would be the direction?
Thank you.
ALAN HARDING: Hi there,
it's Alan Harding here.
I'm president-elect at INCOSE,
but more importantly, I
co-chair our system and
systems working group.
I think the answer
is no to reinvention
because I'm confident
all the principles stand.
But what we've been
doing as a working group,
is identifying where
engineering a system and systems
are different.
We constructed a paper,
which has been published,
on the pain point to
the system of systems,
looking at the managerial and
the technical differences,
and therefore, helping people,
when planning their work,
see in which cases they can
pick up their traditional ways
of looking--
and where, if you, like,
experienced practitioners,
see problems or
challenges in other areas.
So that working group
is helping develop--
so understand and develop
the state practice
for complex system of
systems, and that's
proved quite influential.
And in fact, if you all using
the latest edition of the SE
handbook, in the section
on system of systems,
it does highlight
those pain points.
So they are there helping
shape what people do.
Hopefully, that's of use?
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Thank you, Alan.
Very good.
I think we've only mentioned
system of systems in the class
so far.
We haven't really deep
dived into that topic,
but it's a great point.
OK, and back to MIT.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my question is
about the systems engineering
vision you have on the
web site about 2025.
What has been done about the
protocols or languages that
could be developed to
facilitate the communication
between the systems
engineering professionals
and different stakeholders?
MIKE: That's a really
good question--
you know, this idea of
having the same language.
By the way, I'm Mike Celentano,
deputy technical director
of operations.
The idea of having a common
language is really important.
One of the things that I've
struggled with in health care--
that's my industry--
is trying to convince people
to speak the same language,
and I've since given that up.
What I'm teaching people
now is to understand
the other people's
language, so that they
can communicate better.
And so when you go
from domain to domain,
it's important that you
spend some time learning
the language, a lot like
it's important to learn
how to say hello and goodbye
in the language of the country
that you're visiting.
It's important to understand the
domain that you're exploring,
so that you can make
the interpretation
and help those people
with systems engineering.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, thank you.
DAVID: Ollie, if you don't
mind, I'm going to follow up,
and then Art will as well.
What that question
calls out, and what
I think Mike's
answer calls out, is
there are two very important
dimensions, in my opinion,
of systems engineering.
We are the glue to
the project team,
but we are the glue in
two different dimensions.
There is the engineering
aspect of what we do,
and there is very real
engineering analysis that needs
to occur at the systems level.
We unify the subject
matter experts,
and we bring those
understandings together
whether it's in medical, whether
it's in aerospace, regardless.
But the other aspect that
we cannot avoid as systems
engineers, is the
communication role.
Because we are
working with people
who do not speak the
same common language,
whether that's speaking
between aerospace and medical,
or whether that's on
an aerospace project
speaking between
computer science,
reliability,
mechanical, electrical.
As systems engineers, we must
embrace the communication
aspect and the translator
aspect that Mike called out,
because each of us speak
a different language
for a particular reason.
Art?
ART: And to help in that
regard, one of the products
that INCOSE has helped create
is a systems engineering
body of knowledge, which is
available on a website, which
Ollie is quite familiar with--
which has several
hundred articles
about systems engineering.
But one of the projects
that we are going to be--
and it's its domain
neutral, so it's not
tied to a specific
business sector.
One of the projects that we are
expecting to begin in 2016 is
to create a variant of
that, in some fashion,
for the health care community--
tying it to the unique way they
talk about things--
their approaches, but tie it
back to the common underlying
principles.
And if we are successful
in that, as we expect,
I can imagine us spinning
up ones for transportation,
for telecommunications,
et cetera.
So that that can become a
glue, in essence, for people
across many different
business sectors.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Very good.
So I will make sure
that we provide
the link to the body of
knowledge, which I know
was a very big effort
to put together.
We'll provide that information
for the students as well.
TINA: Great, that's excellent.
Unfortunately, for
time, I'm going
to have to ask Art
to give us a wrap up.
But let me just say one
thing because I'm not sure
how well you can see
the video over here.
But you guys are talking to
a group of about 20 people
from around the world.
We have people here from
France, Sweden, Australia.
And the people that
you just talked to
are also senior engineering
leaders that Airbus and BAE,
and so they kind of arrange a
broad spectrum here-- and also
rose from different industries.
So I'll hand it over to Art
to give you a good summary,
but I hope that you continue to
keep in touch with this group.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Well, this is where
I'm going to make my small
pitch for membership.
So as students, you have an
opportunity for only 38 dollars
US annually to be members of
INCOSE, which gives you access
to all of our products,
which includes videos
that are recorded
every month, handbooks,
all sorts of documents.
And I'd really like
to encourage you
to consider that as an option.
It's great.
It's something like a
quarter of what you'd have
to pay as a full professional.
And so I'm going to
let it go with that.
OLIVIER DE WECK: No, Art,
I think that was great.
And I'll just say
from my perspective,
I first got involved in INCOSE
a little more than a decade ago,
and I think both the
industry-academic mix,
the conferences-- you
know, this is real.
This is not a community
that's living in a bubble,
and so I would I would
fully endorse, Art.
All right, well, I think we're
at the end of this interview.
You know, this is cool.
I mean, that technology
has gotten to the point
where, certainly, the
audio part of this
was very clear for all of
us, and that's terrific.
So we want to thank
you for your time.
Have a great continuation
of your board meeting,
and we're going to keep
learning over here.
DAVID: Very good.
Thank you so much, Ollie.
GUEST SPEAKER: Thank you.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Take care.
All right, well, I hope
you found that useful.
And I'll provide you a link
to the body of knowledge.
I think that's one thing that
we haven't sort of pointed out.
So let's go back to--
EPFL, are you still with us?
GUEST SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, good.
Thank you.
So let me just sort of
finish on the midterm.
Yes, Veronica?
VERONICA: [INAUDIBLE] can I
ask, a question I would have
asked to the board, to you?
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
VERONICA: Thank you.
When I was looking
over their web site,
I see a lot about
kind of communicating
for the sake of engineers
and everything else.
But I think that systems
engineering, in particular,
has an ability to shape the
way that we kind of regulate
policy developments.
I feel like a lot of times
scientific advancement
is working against international
regulatory standards, where
I feel like an
entity like INCOSE
has an ability to kind of shape
international collaboration
in a way that can help
scientists achieve more
together.
And so I was kind of wondering
what the role they might have
seen-- or what you
might see as kind
of an international
collaboration,
like that, taking, in terms of
shaping the ways in which we
engineer together-- not just the
ways in which we kind of create
in systems engineering
naturally, but kind
of more collaborative.
OLIVIER DE WECK: I think
it's a great question.
And I think the system
engineering is sort
of evolving and broadening.
The classic view of system
engineering is you know,
that's what a company
or a big project
that's producing a physical
deliverable, a new airplane,
a new computer, health care
device, a new software system.
That's the out-- you
know, and then that's
a capability that you
put out into the market
and to the field.
And regulations and
policies are given to you--
you know, their constraints,
their requirements.
I think what you're saying is,
well, the policies, themselves,
are something to be designed--
VERONICA: I think so.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
--and negotiated.
And that's a broadening
of the system boundary
and the mandate for
system engineering.
And so here, at MIT, over
the last 15 years or so,
the word we've used for that
is, engineering systems.
So we kind of flipped
the two words,
and say that system engineering,
in a more traditional sense,
is scope, scope, smaller.
And then when you
internalize the externalities
like economics, policy,
and you consider
that part of the
design space as well,
then you're in the world
of engineering systems
or complex
sociotechnical systems.
And so, absolutely, there's a--
and you heard the answer
that Alan Harding, who's
the President-elect of INCOSE.
He will take over from
Dave Long next year.
When he started talking
about system of systems--
well, you know, what
our system of systems?
For example, air
traffic management.
Let's take an example,
air traffic management,
air transportation.
In North America, there's
this project called next-gen--
right, next generation--
that's a very complex
system of systems.
And in Europe, the equivalent
is a project called SESAR.
It's essentially the
Unified European airspace.
Well, you've got-- it's not
just about flight controllers,
and radar stations, and
GPS-enabled navigation.
A lot of it has
to do with policy.
And how do you do the hand offs?
Who is responsible to
report any anomalies?
How do you do backup operations?
And so forth.
So a good example when
that came to the fore is--
I don't know if you remember
the Icelandic volcano
a few years ago?
The volcano erupted, and then
there was this big ash cloud.
And then the question
was, well, is it
safe to fly through
this ash cloud?
And who actually
has the authority
to decide which part of the
airspace is closed and is open?
And then you've got
the airlines saying,
you know, open up the
airspace because we're losing
a lot of business every day.
And the regulators
are saying, wait,
we need to be cautious here.
So I think what you're saying
is that's a system engineering
problem that we could
sort of address.
And so things are
moving that way,
but I think our
methodologies for doing
that work in a rigorous way
are not quite there yet.
It's still evolving,
but great question.
VERONICA: Is that
a type of advocacy
that a group like INCOSE
could move toward?
I can see from their mission
statement and everything,
that's something
they are doing now.
But is that a place that you
see that they could fill?
OLIVIER DE WECK: It could be.
And I think I think
they're moving that way.
VERONICA: Thank you.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah.
OK, any other
points anybody wants
to add from the discussion?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, one
question from our side--
OLIVIER DE WECK: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: --if I can.
So I think that's a very
good point, Veronica,
in terms of how do you transfer
this to policy or business
management?
Some time ago, I was trying
to see if there are actually
jobs or careers that are
called systems engineer,
but besides IT, there's
really not a profession.
For example, if you're doing
this in the policy domain,
could you just be the systems
engineer of, say for example,
the Swiss energy--
you know, what
I'm working on currently--
kind of the Swiss energy
transition-- you know,
the systems engineer,
and that would be your role.
Are their careers
and career names
that are explicitly, like,
designing the systems
and engineering them?
OLIVIER DE WECK: That's
a question, right?
Katya, I think the mic is off.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hear me now?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are there
jobs that do this?
Are there systems
engineering jobs,
or is that project management?
OLIVIER DE WECK:
That's a good question.
So the job profiles of system
engineers have been broadening.
There is also,
system architects.
When we talk about
concept generation here,
concept selection,
that's, in a sense,
a specialty within
system engineering
known as system architecture.
So you'll have more and
more people hand you
a business card that says,
I'm the system architect.
And what that means is they're
in charge of the high level
decisions, the upper left side
of the V that's shown here.
So system architect,
system engineers.
And there's also a very--
this didn't come up
in the discussion with
INCOSE, but there's
a very active discussion
going on right now
between INCOSE, that
has about 10,000 members
and is 25 years old,
and an organization
called PMI, Project Management
Institute, which is older
and has about 400,000
members globally.
And that's the people
running big projects.
So those job
descriptions are still
coming from different
angles, but we
do see this bigger
discussion emerging.
And I think the organizations
that are enlightened,
that really understand that
these big system decisions are
critical-- and that you can't
just make those arbitrarily.
You need people who actually
think about the whole system,
who model and simulate
the whole system, who
look at different scenarios.
You need dedicated
people for that.
Who not just have the education
and the experience to do it,
but have the job title to do
it as well, and the authority.
And so, I think we're
seeing a transition
to those new kinds of jobs,
especially in the enlightened
organizations.
OK.
Yes?
VERONICA: One more, I promise.
OLIVIER DE WECK: One more
and then we'll move on.
Yep?
VERONICA: So when
you say that someone
needs to have a designated
title of a systems engineer
to really do it well, is there
an advantage or disadvantage
to having everyone be a systems
engineer with a specialty,
so that you're training
an entire organization
to think about the big picture?
Because I can see pros and
cons, but I'm wondering,
is there a hard
answer either way.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
My position on this
is-- you remember, we
talked a little bit
about the value of
system engineering,
like how much should you
invest in system engineering?
And we'll come back to
this at the end of term.
But generally, you
can see that there's
empirical data that says you
should spend roughly 10% to 20%
of your budget--
maybe 15% is sort
of the sweet spot--
on systems engineering, system
architecture type activities,
which happens to be 1 in 7.
1 over 7, that's
15% roughly, right?
So if you're going to,
on average, decompose
your systems into seven chunks
at each level of decomposition
then you need about one
out of seven people--
or one out of eight or
one out of seven people--
their primary focus should be
on how the chunks fit together,
not designing the
individual chunks.
And so there's a lot
of empirical evidence
that suggests that if you spend
a lot less effort on system
integration than about
15% of your total budget,
you're going to
have real problems.
You will miss requirements.
You'll have poorly
managed interfaces.
You'll have surprises
during testing.
If you spend a lot more than
15% on system engineering
activities, the project
will be very heavy,
too much bureaucracy,
too many processes.
It gets slower.
So we'll come back to that.
But everybody should
have some understanding
of what system engineering is
even if you're a subject matter
expert specialty person,
if you do cost modeling,
or if you do control
systems, propulsion,
in the medical field,
biocompatible materials.
Whatever it is you do,
everybody should know something
about system engineering.
But then you do need, that's my
opinion, the dedicated people
who really focus on the
integration, the interfaces,
how the chunks fit together.
And if you don't have
that for projects
that are of a certain
level of complexity,
you're going to
have big problems.
OK, Katya, was that
was that reasonable?
All right.
So let's move on here with the
exam because we have a very,
I think, exciting, interesting
presentation to get to.
So the V is essentially--
you have this vision.
You then decompose
requirements, subsystems.
And then the bottom of
the V is the details.
Every little detail
needs to be defined.
And then the right side is we
go and then integrate everything
together, and we
go to operations.
So I think most of you really
explained that quite well.
Question four, what is
the most important aspect
of the V-model that is not
shown explicitly in the V?
There are two answers here,
and I think both are correct.
The iterative nature
of design, we'll
hear about this in
the Octanis project.
So the V-model does not imply
that you're automatically doing
a waterfall stage gate process.
You're only doing
trade studies once.
You're only testing once.
That's not what it means.
It just means that
there's a logical sequence
to the activities,
but you could actually
spiral through the V multiple
times, so the iterative nature
of design.
And then the possibility of
schedule and cost overruns,
this is the programmatic side,
is not shown in the V-model,
but it's implied.
So both of these are correct,
so this is very good.
Question five, at which of
the following milestones
should the main concept, or
architecture, of the system
selected-- so here
we have a little bit
of a spread of answers.
The correct answer here should
be PDR, Polygyny Design Review.
That's when the concept, the
architecture, the high level
decomposition of the system,
the assignment of functions
to those chunks at level one or
level two, should be defined.
SRR, it's too early.
All you're trying to do at
the SRR, System Requirements
Review, is agree on what
the requirements are,
what the system should achieve,
but not necessarily how
that will be achieved.
And then at CDR, I
would say it's too late.
The CDR is where you
lay out all the details
of how the system will be
built, operated, the software.
So that the high level design,
the concept, the architecture,
should have been decided and
agreed upon way before the CDR,
and it's the PDR where
that's happening.
So I think about 3/4 of
you got it right here.
The next one was a
little subtle question.
What are the following
attributes should
a set of requirements meet?
And I put check marks here
between what were the--
so there were multiple
correct answers.
The set of requirements
means multiple,
an ensemble of
requirements, as opposed
to just a single
requirement in isolation.
So, feasible, verifiable,
and unambiguous,
those three answers are correct
for individual requirements.
Each individual requirement
should be feasible, verifiable,
and unambiguous.
But when you look at
a set of requirements,
that's when these other
three come into play,
absence of redundancy.
So what this means is that
you shouldn't replicate
the same requirement,
essentially,
across multiple requirements
in your requirements set.
And one of the
reasons for that is
if you change a requirement
then you might miss it
somewhere else, right.
This redundancy is-- keep it
as simple, as straightforward
as you can.
Completeness, that
basically means
that the requirements
set that you develop
should cover all
the requirements.
You shouldn't have big holes
and missing requirements.
And then the last point
is absence of conflicts.
If you have requirements
conflicts, essentially,
what this means is there's
no feasible solution.
So if you think
about optimization,
you have an
over-constrained problem.
Basically, that's
what that means.
OK?
Any questions about these two?
AUDIENCE: Yes, I have a
question for question five.
I think the question
is a little bit
ambiguous because if
the main concept is
selected on the PDR--
on a timescale on the CDR,
you have the main concept.
So you can say that
on the CDR, it's
also the main concept
selected already.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Ah, I
see what you're saying.
Yeah, so maybe I
should have said,
what is the earliest milestone
at which the concept--
that's really what
I meant, is what's
the milestone where the concept
has to be agreed upon, and then
of course, at the CDR--
unless you had to overturn
your concept selection,
which happens sometimes--
you should stick with the same.
But the intent here was
to say, this is PDR.
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: For this
question, number five,
I think I got concepts
of operations confused
with the concept architecture.
So just to be clear about
that, the concept of operations
is what the system
does, and architecture
just a list of the subsystems
and what are the mass, energy,
and information flow?
Is that correct?
OLIVIER DE WECK: That's right.
The concept of operations,
that's actually an SRR type.
The concept of operations--
AUDIENCE: That's what I put.
OLIVIER DE WECK: --how will
the system be used, right?
And then the concept,
the architecture
is, given this
concept of operations,
what are the functions
that have to happen,
and then which
chunks in your system
support or enable
what functions?
That's essentially what it is.
Yep.
OK, anything else?
All right, question seven.
I think most of
you got this right.
We're going to get to
verification and validation
in a lot more detail, but
there is a distinction.
Some people use verification
and validation interchangeably.
They think it's the same.
It's different words
for the same thing.
That's not quite the case.
So here you've got
your verification loop
and your validation loop.
To put it very succinctly,
in verification,
you're answering the
question, did you
satisfy the requirements
as they were written?
That's the inner loop.
You've got your
requirements set,
and then you do
verification, or inspection,
or there's different
ways of checking that.
But you check, do we
meet the requirements
as they were written?
That's the inner loop.
And then validation is the
outer loop where you say,
go back to the stakeholders,
and then you say the CONOPS,
right-- can we actually
execute the CONOPS--
and does the system
meet the expectations
of the stakeholders?
Does it deliver value to them?
And so it's quite
possible-- and there
are examples of systems that
actually successfully pass
verification.
You can check every
requirements, say, yup, yup,
yup, we can do that.
And then you demonstrate
the product, or the system,
to the stakeholders, and they
say, oh no, that's not at all
what we were looking for.
And then the question is,
well, did you change your mind?
You know, customer,
beneficiary--
did you change the mind from
today to when we started this
project, or was there some
error in translation going from
the stake--
or the stakeholders
didn't change their mind.
You know, their use
cases, their CONOPS,
the value they want
to get from the system
hasn't changed since
you started the project,
but there was some
error in translation
between those high level
stakeholder expectations
and then the requirements.
No, maybe you missed
a requirement.
So that's the key idea
here between V and B,
and we'll talk a lot more about
this in the next few weeks.
All right, now comes
the one you've all
been waiting for, I know.
Question eight.
So here's the rocket equation.
Delta v, the change in velocity
of a rocket that you can
achieve is equal to gravity
times the specific impulse
times the log of
your initial mass--
so this is your rocket
on the launch pad--
and over M i, which is the
final mass after the burn
has happened.
And so, one thing
that's important
is to define those masses.
And we got a lot of emails.
Right, [INAUDIBLE]?
Would you say this
was probably the most
emails we've gotten
all semester-- is
about this question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So
a bunch of questions
were just about the
definition of mass fraction.
What is the mass fraction?
And there are really two
different interpretations
of it.
And it turned out
it didn't matter
which one you used because
the answer was the same.
So the one that I'm
showing you here
is that the initial mass
here is 1 plus alpha times M
f, your mass of fuel,
plus your payload.
So in this case, alpha
is the percentage
of the mass that
you're launching,
the fuel and the payload--
that's made up of
structure, which
includes tankage, support
structure, the engines
themselves, et cetera.
The other definition you could
use which is equally valid,
you just have to define it,
is that alpha is only applied
to the fuel mass, right.
That you've got the
fuel, which in this case
is liquid oxygen,
liquid hydrogen.
And then you have your
tanks and your engine.
That's your mass fraction.
And then the
payload sits on top,
and there's no overhead
for carrying the payload.
And either way, it didn't
matter in this question
because the answer was the same.
So here the initial mass
is 1 plus alpha times
the mass of the fuel,
which is unknown,
and the mass of the payload,
which is given, 20 metric tons.
And then M1 is simply alpha
times mass of the fuel and mass
of the payload.
So you can slightly rearrange--
there are different ways
of solving this problem.
A simple way is this.
You just basically
bring the constants
over to the left side.
So delta V over g i s p, and
then basically, the right side
has to be larger than that.
So this is essentially your
1 plus alpha divided by alpha
because the M f plus
M p term falls out,
if you formulated that way.
So you can just plug
in the numbers that
were given in the
problem, and you
can see that the left hand side
does not match the right hand
side, right?
And the conclusion from this--
some of you tried to
solve for the fuel mass.
You know, there's
all kinds of ways.
And it's super frustrating,
and I know a lot of you
spent a lot of time trying
to solve this problem.
And no matter what way,
you get negative fuel mass.
You get all kinds
of weird things
trying to make this work.
The bottom line is
infeasible requirement.
It's not possible
with the required--
this is an example of an
infeasible requirement.
And I did this on
purpose to show you
that just because somebody
writes a requirement down,
it doesn't mean it's feasible.
So I think many of you got
this and were frustrated by it,
but I want to show you a real
project where this happened.
So you could then ask,
well, what would we
have to do to make it feasible?
So some of you said, well, maybe
we can achieve less delta V?
Or we need even better
propulsion, higher i s p.
Or-- which is maybe a little
bit more straightforward, what
would be the mass fraction,
the alpha, that you would have
to achieve to make this work?
And the answer is
somewhere around 8%,
depending on which definition
of mass fraction you used,
it's 7% to 8%.
So it means that if you want to
achieve single stage to orbit
flight with no staging, which
is the current way we do it,
you have to get the
mass fraction below 8%.
And that includes everything,
the tanks, the support
structure, the engines.
And that's really,
really, really tough.
So I know you were frustrated
by this problem many of you,
but let me tell you this story.
Those folks were
really frustrated.
So there was actually
a program here
in the US in the late '90s
that tried to as a small scale
technology demonstrator
demonstrate the technologies
required to get to orbit
with a single stage vehicle.
And that program was called the
X-33, run by Lockheed Martin--
so, single stage to orbit,
reusable launch vehicle
demonstrator.
The target mass, this is your M
0, total mass, 130 metric tons.
The target mass
fraction was 0.1.
And fuel was just the same as
in this problem, LOX hydrogen.
And the project basically
was canceled in 2001
after about $1.3 billion
had been spent on it,
and the thing that eventually
really led to the cancellation
was the fuel tank.
There was a composite
material fuel tank
that was embedded inside the
wing here, inside this body,
has very complex shape.
And those of you that know
about-- hydrogen atoms
are very, very small.
It's very tough to contain
hydrogen. It wants to leak.
Its natural tendency
is to leak out.
So this composite
fuel tank basically
couldn't be built and
tested under pressure
to be leak proof, and
they really tried.
They spent a lot of money
on it, a lot of effort,
couldn't be done.
And so NASA
concluded, you know--
and the goal was to achieve,
essentially, this mass fraction
of 10% or below.
And at that time, in the
late '90s, early 2000s,
this was just not feasible
with the state of technology.
And so, think about
how frustrated--
I know you spent an hour
or so trying to solve this,
and we're not happy about it.
But think about how they
felt. So the purpose of this--
I think most of
this midterm exam
was kind of a gift up
until this question.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
about the mass fraction.
I read the text over there,
and it says it's suborbital.
So was the plan to reduce the
mass fraction even further
if this was a success?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Right,
so this would not
have achieved orbital velocity.
So it's not a
complete one to one
map because I gave you also
a higher delta V, right?
I gave you 11
kilometers per second,
which is escape velocity, and
you need to achieve about 7.5.
But with drag and
gravity losses,
you really needed
achieve about 9, 9.5.
So it's not a one to one map,
but you sort of get the idea.
Any question about this at EPFL?
Did you hear this?
Was it was it fairly clear?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think everything
is clear on our side.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
All right, so if you
want to read more
about the X-33,
the Wikipedia article is
pretty good and there's a lot.
So just to say,
you know, I think
we're going to try this again.
I think there's going
to be new efforts.
Composite materials
have come a long way--
composite manufacturing,
15 years later,
we might try this
again pretty soon.
OK, question nine.
So this was a little
bit of computation here.
So the intent of
this question was
for you to think about
competing objectives.
Right, the Pareto frontiers,
we talked about this
in the concept selection.
So this is the idea of, you're
designing a can or container
for containing liquids.
The shape is cylindrical
as shown in red.
And so the two things
you care about is volume.
How much liquid can you
carry inside the can?
That's simply pi r-squared h--
and then your
surface area, which
you could say that's the
cost of the container, right.
That's the amount of material
you need to use, is 2 pi r.
Those at the top and bottom.
And then 2 r pi h, which
is your circumference.
And if you then plot four
different combinations
of radius and height, what
is the volume and surface
area, which is shown
in this plot here?
Surface area as the y-axis
and volume on the x-axis.
The idea is you want
to maximize volume
while minimizing
surface area by changing
the radius and the height
subject to these constraints
shown here, you should
have gotten something that
looks like this blue curve.
This is the Pareto frontier,
and the question was, well,
where's the Utopia Point?
The Utopia Point is
down to the lower right.
Maybe you plotted it
differently, and that's fine.
So you want as high
a volume as you
can with minimum surface area,
but the best you can achieve--
there's nothing in
this white space here.
The best you can achieve is
this blue curve and above it.
And so then I'm plotting
to a small and a big one.
So the Coca-Cola can is shown.
The soda can is in
the lower left corner,
and you can see it's pretty
much on the Pareto front.
And then this is the standard
55 US gallon oil barrels.
You know, if you go to like
a junkyard or a refinery,
you'll see these barrels of oil.
Actually, it's not exactly
on the Pareto front,
but it's very, very close.
So that was the intent here.
Any questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you trying
to determine whether or not
the oil and the soda can
were on the Pareto front,
didn't that depend on how
you defined the assumptions?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Not really,
one of the key assumptions
that was given was that you
should assume zero thickness.
Right, so it's just a
volume versus surface.
There's no actual thickness.
AUDIENCE: In terms of the--
I need to double check the--
so when I looked at the
height of the different cans,
were we supposed to leave
the problem as defined
in terms of the original units?
If you updated the units
as the maximum height
to be within a more reasonable
range, not 2 meters versus 900
millimeters, neither point
was on the Pareto front.
It just depended on how well you
defined your upper limit to be.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: And I was
wondering if we were expected
to maintain the
original upper limit,
or if we were
allowed to change it.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Oh, if
you change it, that's fine.
AUDIENCE: OK.
OLIVIER DE WECK: The basic
idea of this question
was to understand what
is a Pareto frontier.
And you know, to actually
think about something
we use almost every day.
You know, we drink a soda
or something like that,
and that shape is not a
randomly selected shape.
It's actually based
on a trade off
between volume and efficiency--
right, volume and surface area.
And here you go, here's where
it falls on the Pareto frontier.
That's sort of the general idea.
Well, we haven't
graded the exams yet,
but I think we'll be fairly
generous on this question.
OK, so then the last
one was really the--
that's very recent happenings.
If you read the article,
you realized, wow,
there's kind of a
prehistory here.
This is not just something
that happened a month ago.
There's a long history leading
up to this emissions scandal,
and the key table in the article
is this table shown here.
It's essentially
these n o x numbers
for emissions where you had
the different-- so these
are requirements.
These are regulatory
requirements.
And a big part of the story
is that the requirements--
this is just for diesel
engines, the supplies
for diesel engines in the US
and in Europe are different.
And so you can see that
the limit is essentially
the regulatory requirement.
The dyno shown in green
here is demonstrate--
this is verification.
Did you satisfy the
requirement as written?
And you can argue that because
these vehicles had software
in them, the purpose
of the software
was to detect whether
or not the vehicle is
being tested for emissions.
And the reason you can do it
is because the drive cycles
are very tightly prescribed.
So if the vehicle
is operating exactly
at the speeds and
velocities that
correspond one to one to
those test drive cycles,
the software knew, ah, I'm
being tested for emissions.
And you know, it's like
knowing that you're
being watched as
a kid, and you're
behaving because you know
you're being watched.
And then whenever you think
you're not being watched,
you do something very different.
That's the general idea.
So the green was
basically the dyno results
with the cheating, essentially,
with the software embedded.
And then the West Virginia
University results,
which were this
independent testing,
showed that the actual emissions
during regular operations
were about 30 times
worse than this.
And the trade off here is, of
course, with fuel efficiency.
That's the big trade off.
And so, we haven't read your
answers yet to this question,
but it's extremely relevant
to system engineering
and in particular,
to the distinction
between verification
and validation.
So you can argue that
verification was passed here
because it passes the dyno test.
These are the regulatory
tests that are prescribed,
but it fails,
essentially, in the field
to satisfy the requirements.
And of course,
Volkswagen has admitted
that they cheated in essence.
But I'll be very interested to
see how the legal side of this
works out because if you
interpret this very narrowly--
and you cannot say that those
vehicles failed their emission
standard tests because they've
performed properly on the dyno.
So to what extent are
these requirements,
these environmental
requirements, which are very,
in a sense, narrowly
defined in terms
of how these requirements
are verified legally binding
in terms of being able to
perform at those levels
outside of the drive
cycle test cases
that are prescribed by law?
Did you see what I'm saying?
So even though morally,
people generally
say that Volkswagen has cheated
because they're essentially
reconfiguring the vehicle
depending on whether it's
being tested officially or not.
But from a legal
perspective, I'm
not sure this is fully
done yet, so we'll
have to see how the lawsuits
and all these things play out.
Go ahead [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Would you
would you say that,
looking at it from the
regulators perspective,
that they had set up
an expectation that
didn't flow into a requirement?
And if it was a requirement,
it was unverifiable until WVU--
it was an unverifiable
requirement in a sense.
OLIVIER DE WECK: That's
one way to say it.
And you know, what is
the response to this?
Well, one response could be
that a whole bunch of more test
cases--
you know, the
actual drive cycles
that are going to
have to be tested
are going to be much more--
I don't know.
We'll see.
This is a big deal not
just for Volkswagon,
but I think it's a very big deal
in the bigger picture of how
do regulatory requirements
and standards apply
to all kinds of products,
and how do you check them.
Let's see real quick if
there is a question at EPFL.
Any comments, questions?
AUDIENCE: Regulation,
actually, in Europe,
it was forbidden and
explicitly forbidden
to introduce a [? defect ?]
device in the car.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah, and
there's penalties for that,
right?
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, good.
Nathan, you had a point?
NATHAN: I was
wondering if you've
seen any analysis on like WVU
doing tests on other vehicles
to compare what they show on
their dyno results versus what
they're admitting in real
life, even though it might not
be this extreme.
OLIVIER DE WECK: I don't know.
I don't know what tests
they've done internally.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it's
like a result [INAUDIBLE]----
what do you call it?
The test being so different from
the actual real life driving
because nobody accelerates
from zero to 30 in 30 seconds.
That's what they've
been testing.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah.
So there's a real,
real strong connection
here with system engineering.
And that was the purpose of this
question, is to sort of push--
this question was not a gift.
This sort of really
required you to dig in,
and it was very timely, I think.
So cheat to meet requirements
failed validation.
That's what I would
say as a quick summary.
Any final questions,
comments about the online--
the quiz, the midterm quiz?
OK, we've had we've had
our interactive discussion
with the INCOSE
board of directors,
so hopefully you enjoyed that.
And we are now right on time
to hand it over to Octanis.
And Rafael will present this--
Rafael Fabian Tychui.
So essentially, you'll hear it's
about the design manufacturing
and deployment of a rover
for extreme environment--
Antarctica, in particular.
And so, we look forward
to Rafael's presentation.
And as you listen
to Rafael, think
about what you
learned in this class
so far, how does it connect.
And I think Rafael also tried
to gear the presentation a bit
to the system
engineering concepts.
RAFAEL: So I'm Rafael.
I'm just going to
present myself quickly.
I'm studying here at my master's
in nano and micro-electronics,
and I'm speaking on
behalf of Octanis.
So just in case, the image
quality wouldn't be perfect,
you can find this presentation
at MIT and on tiny.cc/octanis
just to see the picture.
And well, Octanis
is an association
that was just recently founded.
We have certain key values.
So fascination is one of them.
We set in-shop goals and then
get very passionate about this.
We want to build
affordable products,
so we use open source software,
we 3D print parts, and so on.
We use off-the-shelf components.
And we want to do open design,
so we share our code on GitHub.
We share our mechanical
designs to the community.
And one point is also
education, so we, ourselves,
want to learn from
what we're doing
and want to make others
benefit from our learning,
and try to help them, as
well, with their projects.
And how we tackle things is kind
of summarized in this statement
from Tom Chi from Google X.
So we minimise the time to try
things and maximize
the time of learning.
That means we iterate very fast.
We do a prototype very fast.
We go on with the
idea, with a prototype,
with a sketch, a
design, and so on.
And we try it.
If you fail, just move,
try the next thing.
And you know, that's
basically how it is.
And the first project that just
emerged out of this procedure
is Octanis I, so that's what
I'm going to talk about today.
So maybe quickly
about the team--
so the rule 7 plus minus 1--
plus minus 2 applies
here as well.
So we are eight members
now working on that rover--
from different fields,
from engineering, physics,
life science as well.
And the story began actually
when Sam was here as well.
For the QHN, just in case.
And Anna found about this
competition or that call
from Ecuador that
was about building--
or sending a student project,
or whatever, to Antarctica.
And they thought, well,
let's [INAUDIBLE] take
this challenge, and we're going
to put a rover on a weather
balloon, send it from South
America to Antarctica,
deploy it there, let it
drive around for one summer.
And let's see what happens.
And well, they
started immediately
with doing simulations.
There's the online tool that
allows to kind of predict
the optimal time for a
trajectory in the air, so
a particle or an
object in the air that
will have a desired trajectory.
And you can kind of find out
the best moment in the year
to do this.
And it was actually
demonstrated, kind of,
to show that this is possible
to have this trajectory.
Well, I heard about this
later, and they asked me
if I could do the
electronics design of this--
so the main board and so on.
And I was fascinated
by the project,
so I joined immediately,
but at the same time,
I saw all the challenges that
we're going to have to solve.
So I thought about all
the problems we have.
For instance, what happens if we
lose the balloon in the ocean?
What happens if we run out
of power and the temperature
drops--
if an arm breaks, and you
know, we cannot get up anymore?
But at some point,
I just realized
that, well, all we do is
we just send a balloon
with the rover to
Antarctica, and we're
going to deploy it there,
and it will drive it down.
And I think that
that's something
we saw also in this
class because I'm
following this class passively
on WebEx and with the videos.
So yeah, the thing
that you have to see
is the big picture as a
system engineer, right.
You see the whole
mission, and you
don't care about the
details at this level.
But you're going to
decompose the problem
into specific sub-problems
and have groups of people
working on this, and that's it.
So it just looked easy to me.
In the end, we're
just going to do it,
and we started with
the first problem.
And just to give
you an idea, that's
one of our last prototypes.
So that's how the rover
is going to look like.
We see two struts with wheels
on each side, solar panels
and 3D printed parts for 3D
printed wheels and struts.
And you see the
balloon in our logo.
And we're not going to
do the balloon right now,
but the first mission will
just be the rover itself.
And that slide basically
summarizes the goal.
So the mission of Octanis I is
to build a reusable autonomous
solar powered and open source
for outdoors, and in this case,
for an extreme environment
like Antarctica.
So let's go down
to V-model, right.
We'll start with the
stakeholder analysis.
In our case, it's pretty simple.
It's the Antarctic
Institute from Ecuador,
which we contacted and
showed our project,
and they were pretty happy about
this, and I want to learn more.
So we presented our project.
We sent in a proposal
and are right now,
writing the final
documents for them.
And what we basically
have to provide
is just the goals of the mission
and the scientific findings
we're going to have, so
we will produce a paper
at the end of this and
write about what we found.
And further down, the V-models,
will be the requirements.
So we can look at some
Shall requirements.
So the power system of the
rover shall provide 10 watts
on average, so we
figured that out after
like riding on a power budget.
Should We want to drive around
that will cost that much power,
and that will be that much
time during the day, and so on.
So that was the number
we came up with.
Oh, and the interior
temperature shall not
drop below minus
20 degrees Celsius,
so about 10 Fahrenheit.
That's basically the point where
you cannot charge the battery
any more because of the
chemical composition of it.
So standard batteries,
you shouldn't
go below minus 10 degrees.
That's really a hard
requirement we have to provide.
The total weight shall
not exceed 2.5 kilograms.
Basically, we look already for
the mission, for the balloons--
so it shouldn't be too
expensive to put the helium--
like, to buy the
helium and so on.
And the rover shall be
able to communicate to us
from any point of the Earth.
For that, they basically
used the Iridium Network,
which you can pay like
for a text message.
You can pay something and
you can send your message
from any point as well.
There's a bunch of satellites
covering the whole planet
basically.
And [INAUDIBLE] managed to climb
the slope, a certain slope.
That's just to assure
that we can not just
drive on flat terrain.
There's also some
should requirements.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Rafael, quick question.
RAFAEL: Yes?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Where did
the 14 degrees come from?
Did you do like a terrain
analysis on Antarctica,
or how did you come up with
14 degrees as the requirement
for this hill climbing?
RAFAEL: We basically
looked at the motors
we would have in mind to
take, and then figured out
that that's basically
what they can do.
And we tested it.
So I'm going to talk
about this later.
We didn't do this up, down only,
but we looked at what we have
and what we can do.
And that's what we
figured out would
be a reasonable kind of choice,
but yeah, good question.
So the should requirements
cover reproducibility,
so any non-expert should
also be able to build
this rover without being
an engineer user as well.
The cost should
stay below $1,000,
so the material costs only,
of course, not the R&D.
The range should be
around 1 kilometers a day.
That's kind in the order of
magnitude of the Curiosity
Rover, so we're not stressed.
We don't have to go fast.
We have weeks or months to be
there, so one kilometer per day
is just fine.
There should be for
a scientific payload.
Room means physical
space and also
certain conditions like
temperature, humidity inside,
depending on the experiment.
And well, it should survive
one Antarctic summer,
so that implies
also the conditions
that we have there like
the weather and the sun,
the radiation, and so on.
So with all of this done,
we had our first diagram,
so pardon the [INAUDIBLE].
Our representation is not
what we learned in this class,
but that's what we had, right?
So this graph is mostly
on the electronics.
It's focused.
There's a main
board in the middle.
I'm not sure if you
see that clearly,
but a main board with a
bunch of sensors up here,
and also a camera, and RF
modules for communications,
and maxillary board for
the scientific payload,
for instance.
And we kept going with this,
and we basically designed a PCB
with all these components.
And most of it worked as well.
We also thought about
the mechanics of course.
This design is inspired
from a NASA project that
was, in the end,
abandoned because it was
too high in cost, but still--
this manner of
[INAUDIBLE] was kind
of having the same
structure-- so two struts
that would allow to flip the
rover entirely around if it
gets clipped by the wind,
and also put it more flat
or align it to the
sun, so that it
gets the maximum of the energy.
And yeah, that's what we had.
And we went out with
our first prototype.
It's pretty cute, right?
We went to Sweden with that.
It has a bunch of cheap Chinese
solar cells from the eBay.
And the rules and everything
are already 3D printed.
Printed It has our
first main board,
and it was just capable of
driving around somewhere
on the snow.
And we [INAUDIBLE] testing
the parachute, so [INAUDIBLE]
came back.
And it worked a few
times, but in the end,
it had kind of an incident.
So we could really test it
and analyze what happened,
and so really what
we can improve
for the further iterations.
And I stopped before
at the remodel.
I want to go down a bit
deeper there and show everyone
a few examples.
So that that's the
electoral power system.
And I want to summarize again,
that the relevant requirements
that are 10 watts on average
that should be produced
and the temperature that should
be held inside the rover.
So we have this choice of
having the small, one chip
solution on the left.
That was cheap.
It was easy.
It was reliable.
Or we could have that
more complex system
where we have more flexibility.
We have, actually, more power
output than the small chip,
and it's basically adaptable
to what we need exactly.
And we, in the end,
went for the second--
for the right option mainly
because of the power output
because the 10 wants imply--
a few amps, actually, of output
and a solar powered input
that would have to be managed.
And that's just not
possible for the small chip
we had in our first
prototype actually.
So we had a concept
that was inspired
from the Swiss [? Cube ?]
Satellite because I remember
going to work there
for his masterpiece,
and he got inspired from
his concept of having
this particular
architecture that implies
having a shared VSS buss.
So you had your 3 volts
that was feed [INAUDIBLE]
to your system, and
directly to that,
connected to solar
panels and the battery.
And if the power bus would
drop below the 3.3 volts,
it will get regulated or
stabilized by discharging
the battery or by solar power,
but you cannot kind of steer
this.
And if it will be too
high then 3.3 volts,
it will [INAUDIBLE] it again
with charging the battery.
And that was basically
the main concept
that he implemented then.
And the next steps,
if you go further,
would be the component
selection, the PCB design,
right.
The [INAUDIBLE]
materials-- right now,
we're programming the framework.
And testing, that's
also ongoing.
And at the same time,
optimized for having cheaper
components-- components
with the smaller footprint,
so you save space on
your PCB and so on.
So that would be really at
the bottom of the [INAUDIBLE]
right now.
Also, maybe, a good example
that shows this trade space
exploration would be
the mechanical design.
So the driving mechanism,
that could be--
well, wheels like we had
it, but it could also
be like caterpillar or any
other kind of mechanism.
The motors could be cheap
ones from eBay for $3 a piece
or like high end Maxon motors
we all love here in Switzerland,
right?
And well, you could
print that with a 3D
printer, the structure.
Even the gears, you
can print them out,
actually, yourself,
with plastic.
It works actually.
Or you could select
metallic parts.
We have also a few--
like, the worm guy for instance,
we need to take a metallic one.
In the end, we had a combination
of all of these things.
So we had the struts.
We also have the Maxon motors
that were sponsored luckily,
so the price isn't too high--
and the metallic worm guy,
as I said, 3D printed struts,
3D printed wheels.
And in the end, there was
a trade off between costs,
reproducibility, reliability,
the range of the robot as well,
and the maximum slopes
you could do as well.
So what we could have
done was this [INAUDIBLE]
metrics, or the further points,
to optimize this design,
but we figured out that
kind of without this,
we just decided, kind of, to
take one of these options,
I think.
So that was what we learned
from the prototype one.
And then the second one,
we had a few adaptions.
So we changed our
main microcontroller.
We changed the RF module
to a standard that
is now emerging called LoRa.
And we also added that
power system I talked about.
But mainly, it remained
the same on that diagram.
And just to show
you how we actually
are looking at that goal that
we are having the rover that
is reproducible by someone.
This looks pretty much
like a kit, right?
Its all 3D printed parts.
You can just assemble them,
the solar cells and you
know, the structure
to build the body.
And looking at this, you might
see that it's not many parts.
It's almost, as we
discussed, within the range
of a non-complex systems that
could be managed by one person.
But in the end, for instance,
the solar panels that are,
again, decomposable
in separate parts.
We manufactured them ourselves
taking blemished cells
from eBay, putting
them into arrays,
soldering the connection.
So in the end, you have a
lot of individual parts--
also, all the parts
on the PCB and so on,
so it quickly explodes in size.
The second prototype
had more power
because of the solar cells--
and also improved
mechanical design,
so that the wheels were
lighter and more stable--
also, the struts and so on.
And we tested that again,
this summer, on a glacier
here in Switzerland.
And to wrap that all
up, just a few points,
we didn't maybe do
like an industry
or like we saw it in this class.
So as I talked earlier
about this before,
we mainly had this
bottom up approach.
We also had a global
vision, at first,
to define the subsystems and
so on, but we didn't strictly
iterate from the top of
the model to down part
because sometimes we just
saw that great components--
for instance, the RF module--
that will provide us with all
a lower power consumption,
a higher range, and
was just perfectly
adaptive for our mission.
So we are stuck with this
one, and integrated it
in the design, and built
the rest of the components
around it.
There's also, of course-- we
didn't have like formal PDR
or CDR because we were a small
team and also because we're not
doing this--
let's say, as a main--
well, yes, it is kind
of a main occupation,
but we're still studying
next to it [INAUDIBLE]..
Also, we may change our
design decision on the way,
not like the complete design
but minor, minor things of it.
And we mainly focus
on this approach
to do rapid prototyping and do
a lot of iterations on one thing
instead of making
first concept studies,
and then select the
best one, and only then
really go to build
it, and cut metal--
that's [INAUDIBLE].
That we can do
because we basically
have all these low cost
components, so it doesn't cost
us a lot to build one
prototype because everything
is 3D printed,
everything is electronics
that is pretty cheaply
doable right now.
And yeah, we can do this.
And to motivate us, or
to give us some pressure,
we set these
artificial deadlines.
So we put the design
freezes in our calendar.
So from this point
on, we will not
change these parts of
the systems any more.
That allows us to kind
of move on on this
and get some things
custom, for granted,
so we don't have to adapt
other things because something
else changed again.
And we have these field
tests like I talked about
in Sweden and on the
glaciers, so that gives us
kind of pressure as well.
Because I remember before
the week in Sweden,
we basically relayed in the
lab, and we spent the night
to keep the 3D printer running.
And as soon as the part was
done, put the next one on,
and you know, changing our--
being there in shifts
to keep it running.
And that was a great experience
because you really have that
thing to be done because
it cannot be 3D printed
in [INAUDIBLE] method.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Rafael, so why don't you
go one more minute
because we want
to do a couple of
questions also, yeah?
RAFAEL: Yeah, I'm
almost done actually.
So how we structure all this
data is basically on the Wiki.
That allows you to go deeper
into the different parts,
and we use Trello for
defining milestones.
It's an online tool--
can use for free.
And the major
systems engineering
challenges I saw here was
especially the time management,
and human factor as well
because you kind of need
to have this boundary
between someone who's
doing the mechanical
design, someone's
who is doing the
electronics design.
Don't cross the boundary
because that person
is an expert in his field.
And if you just come
up with something--
hey, why don't you
do this with this?
First of all, it will
annoy the person.
And second of all
it's like, that person
has made a lot of
thought in this,
and you shouldn't just
come with your thing
you have done in five minutes.
Ask the right questions.
And [INAUDIBLE] thought,
it's difficult to just put
the design on paper
for components
you haven't even tested before.
So just like a few
seconds left for this.
We go out to
[INAUDIBLE] as well.
So we're going to test
this rover in February
in Antarctica.
We can only send
one person to there,
so we have this
agreement within 30 days.
And they allowed us to send
one person in February 2016
to Antarctica, and it's none
of us who's going to go.
But it might be someone
or someone else.
And you have that chance to go
there, all expenses covered,
and you will be there
as a field scientist,
collaborate with the bases,
and basically produce
a paper at the end of this.
If you're interested,
octanis.org/apply.
You'll find all the
information's there.
And the deadline is
tomorrow actually.
OLIVIER DE WECK: All
right, just in time.
Thank you, let's
give Rafael a hand.
OK, so we have like three to
four minutes for questions,
so let's start with
questions at EPFL
and then one question--
we'll go back and forth.
AUDIENCE: And just maybe
a critical question,
why did you choose to switch
from your first communication
[INAUDIBLE] after?
RAFAEL: [INAUDIBLE]
thing we had before?
AUDIENCE: Yes, and
why did you change?
RAFAEL: Before we had
kind of a DIY component
that was called AHX 1 that
there you basically had
to modulate the
signal that you're
going to transmit yourself, and
it was just way too complex.
The new component, you can
just send zero commands
by [INAUDIBLE],, and it
will just do its job.
And it's higher range, as well,
and lower power consumption.
AUDIENCE: And how you shoot
to have a [INAUDIBLE]??
RAFAEL: Oh, sorry,
yeah, that component's
only to communicate from
the rover to the base,
so that will be
like 20 kilometers.
For the coverage to the land,
we'll use the Iridium network.
Any questions at MIT?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Sam?
SAM: This is really
interesting, thanks.
So I was wondering,
with your focus
on openness and
affordability, I guess, do
you foresee any participation
by the public in terms
of like prototyping and testing
or even improving the design--
and/or data analysis?
RAFAEL: Yeah, well,
we're completely open,
so we are based here in
[INAUDIBLE] in a place
called [INAUDIBLE] hacker
space, maker space,
whatever you want to call it.
We have open nights over
Wednesdays, so anyone can come.
And all our design is
on GitHub, so if there's
going to be remote
collaborations,
we would really appreciate that.
So anyone who is
interested in the project,
you can go on our
website, octanis.org/join,
and we [INAUDIBLE] to
collaborate, of course.
Does that answer your question?
SAM: Yes, thank you.
OLIVIER DE WECK: I'd like
to ask you a question.
So you know, I think one of
the things that was quite--
first of all, the enthusiasm
that you guys have
is infectious.
It's very clear
you guys are very
passionate about this mission,
and it's very exciting.
The fact that you didn't
do these milestones,
you didn't do a
formal PDR or CDR,
but you're doing essentially,
kind of spiral development.
So two questions,
one is how many
more spirals do you think
you'll be able to do before you
actually deploy the rover?
Because you said
you did two spirals.
It sounds like so far.
So how many more spirals?
And how will you know whether
your mission was successful
or not?
So what are the success
criteria in the end?
When you look back at
the actual operation,
how will you decide whether
you were successful or not?
RAFAEL: OK, thank you.
So for the first one,
we had our design freeze
for the last iteration already.
The truth is we're still
adapting some points of it
because technically, we
decided on all the parts,
and we're just
implementing it right now,
and refinding it, and
correcting the bugs.
So that was actually done.
And we're now building
the last prototype
or the last, actually, robot
that is going to go there.
And on the thing about
achieving our goal,
so what are the
mission criterias,
that's going to be written
down in the project proposal,
or the paper, that we're going
to give to our stakeholders.
So the Antarctica
Institute of Ecuador.
So one part will be the
power autonomy and also
the communication--
like, it has a
reliable communication.
And one part will be also
the scientific payload,
there will be insights
of conducting experiments
on the field.
You want to add something, Sam?
SAM: Yes, 100 meters
per day [INAUDIBLE]
Very concrete
goals, can we drive
100 meters per day, yes or no?
Can we log every
minute, every data point
that we collect temperature
pressure, et cetera?
Can we log that, and can
we send that to the base?
Like, does the 15
kilometer range of the LoRa
is that [INAUDIBLE] or not?
Does that work?
And of course, does the
satellite communications work?
So once they will send
back a summary of the data,
and we want to
see if that works,
if we can calculate
all the stuff that we
want, on the rover,
and if we get
that stuff back [INAUDIBLE]?
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Good, thank you.
One final question?
Anybody at EPFL?
Here at MIT?
OK, Sam has one more.
SAM: I just have
a question about--
because it's going to be, I
guess, situated near our base,
is there any thought
about, sort of like,
how maintenance would work
when it's in operation
or if something happens?
RAFAEL: Well, the person
who is going to be there
will be in charge of
doing maintenance,
so if something happens,
if it gets stuck somewhere,
he will rescue it.
And if some parts fall, he'll
provide the replacement parts,
of course, so we will not
just send that thing there
and hope it works.
Yeah, we have some
backup plans as well.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK.
SAM: Great.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Sounds
like Sam is interested.
RAFAEL: We have another
question here at EPFL as well.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
OK, do one more,
and then we'll
close the session.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
was just wondering
if you believe-- if you had
followed all what we have seen
here in this class about
the procedures, PDR, CDR,
and so on, would that
have hindered you
in being so reactive?
Or do you feel that you
can be reactive while still
following all those procedures?
RAFAEL: A good
question, thank you.
Certain points of the
concepts that we have seen
would have improved,
especially the efficiency
in the design procedure.
So going down step
by step would help
us to exactly create
what we defined before
and not go too much into
different directions.
But on the other hand, the fact
that we explore our traits,
those [INAUDIBLE]
in the beginning,
makes that we might have an
even better solution because we
wouldn't have thought
about this before when
we were in the upper
part of the [INAUDIBLE]..
So it's kind of a mix.
I think a mix of this is
really the perfect approach
for our project.